ever notice how politicians and
journalists use exactly the same talking
points
congressman Devin Nunez has noticed that
he's been at the heart of the Russia
probe from the very beginning he knows
better than anyone what official
Washington did to reverse the 2016
election that story has told the new
book the plot against the president the
true story about congressman Devin Nunez
uncovered the biggest political scandal
in history by Lee Smith which by the way
at this hour apparently is number one on
Amazon which tells you a lot
congressman newness of California joins
us tonight Carson thanks so much for
coming on thank you thank you and the
channel is very kind but there was a lot
of people that did a lot of great work
yeah I'm gonna read it I think it sounds
Lee Smith is a credible reporter tell me
what you make of journalists in
Washington demanding that we stop asking
questions typically our default is
always we want to know more where the
asker is of quite that's our job and yet
they're telling us no more questions why
are they telling us that well not only
that it's even worse now you know you
had on the conspiracy theories they're
chasing daily conspiracy theories on
this Ukraine hoax and so what I've been
trying to tell my colleagues that if
these are mainstream reporters and
they're out there asking you questions
about conspiracy theories about Trump
and you know what do you think about you
know did did you send anybody to this
place I mean every day is a new
conspiracy theory and when I walk down
the halls I have to continue to tell
these reporters that look I'm not going
to talk to you in this lifetime or the
next because these aren't real reporters
they're assassins there are assassins
that are taking information from the
Democrats on the Intelligence Committee
and they're spreading it out there and
so well their DNC operatives of their
operatives yeah you know and we need a
free press we need a free and fair press
but that's not what we have today well I
don't know I mean on this show we're not
always rushing reflexively to defend
Trump and everything I don't work for
Trump I say whatever not these people
work for the Democratic Party there's
hacks so let me ask you what you know
why don't we know at this late date
what exactly happened why haven't we
seen to name one among many examples the
the full FISA applications yeah
so that's waiting on Horowitz the FISA
application specifically so Horowitz is
gathering all the evidence it's finished
he notified Congress that it's finished
he said last Friday I believe that
it's gonna have very few redactions so
that would tell me that we're gonna get
to see a lot of what went into that FISA
when it when you go to the broader
investigation you know why did molar
spend thirty five million dollars and
not get to the bottom of what actually
happened looking and I think this is
this really needs to happen there are
investigators and lawyers that were on
the Moller team that also have to be
looked at because if they did get to the
bottom of some of the stuff that
Durham's gonna get to the bottom of and
Horowitz is gonna get to the bottom of I
think we have a lot to be concerned
about I'm just just today another
breaking news you know there's always
breaking news every single day on this
subject but general Flynn who was
maligned okay and it's in lead talks
about it in his book he was maligned
back in 2014 they really maligned him in
2016 said he had this Russian girlfriend
it was all nonsense so finally today a
judge cancelled the Flynn hearing so I'm
hopeful that the judge will read what
Flynn's lawyers now have put in front of
the judge and hopefully the the judge
will throw this out and this is not a
way to treat a war hero of course not
meanwhile he's not the only one I mean
next week Roger stone is going on trial
in this city likely to spend the rest of
his life in prison because why okay well
that's gonna be questionable we'll see
what happens with that there's there's a
lot more I think to be learned on that
case I think there is congressman thanks
as always for coming on I appreciate it
my pleasure as always